انضم الينا الان من الناصره السييد محمود
يزبك الخبير بالشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد
محمود اهلا بك نريد ان نبدا
بتصريحات وزير التراث الاسرائيليه الذي في
كل مره يصرح يثير ضجه ويذهب الى ابعد ما
يمكن في تصريحات اليوم ينادي بتعزيز
الهجره وكذلك ايجاد طرق اكثر ايلاما
للفلسطينيين من الموت في حد ذاته كيف تقرا
هذه التصريحات في هذا
التوقيت واضح انه هذه التصريح هي جزء من
يعني التصريحات السياسيه للاحزاب اليمينيه
في اسرائيل ويعني ليس فقط اليمين المتطرف
يعني في داخل حزب الليكود الذي لا يعتبر
بين قوسين يمينا متطرفا سمعنا يعني
تصريحات مشابهه لانه في هنالك من يعتقد
مازال في اسرائيل انه يستطيع ان يدغدغ
مشاعر الجمهور الاسرائيلي حينما يتحدث عن
الترانسفير جديد او نكبه جديده
للفلسطينيين كما حدث في عام 4 وحتى انه
بعض الصحفيين على وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وخاصه شاشات التلفزيون صرحوا
بشكل واضح انه ما يحدث الان وما يجب ان
يحدث الان هو نكبه فلسطينيه جديده في غزه
معنى ذلك انه ترانسفير وطرد السكان من من
قطاع غزه وطبعا هذه التصريحات الان هي جزء
من لائحه الاتهام في محكمه في المحكمه
العدل الدوليه في لهاي وهذه التصريحات
بالنهايه هي يعني من اجل سسب تاييد لدى
الجمهور اليميني في اسرائيل وهي تندرج تحت
يعني مستوى السياسي للصراع بين الاحزاب
المختلفه الاسرائيليه وهنالك من يعتقد انه
كلما شدد موقفه اعلاميا وكلامي يؤدي هذا
الى كسب اصوات اكثر في صندوق الانتخابات
المقبله ولكن الشيء الخطير في هذه
التصريحات انه حينما تاتي من جهات كثيره
تصبح جزءا من الكلام الشعب الاسرائيلي
لذلك يعني احيانا يعني يصعب التفرق ما بين
مصلحه انتخابيه لهذا الشخص او ذاك الشخص
وما بين
الحديث الرسمي للمجموعات الشعبيه في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي فيصبح هذا التصريح
الطرد او الترانسفير او النكبه جديده وكن
سيد محمود السنا في واقع الامر امام نموذج
فعلي لهذه العناوين العريضه التي يتحدث
عنها بسياق انتخابي كما ذكرت وزير التراث
اليس ما يحدث من تدمير للبيوت توسيع
الاستيطان محاوله الدفع بالمواطنين الى
اقصى المناطق في تحت حجه انها امنه اليس
هذا تطبيقا فعليا لما يتحدث عنه وزير
التراث نعم هذا 100% انا يعني متفقين في
ذلك ولكن يعني انا ما احاول اقوله كذلك
انه هنالك نوع من من خلال العمل على
الساحه يعني في الواقع في قطاع ز عمل يوجد
تجيج للشارع الاسرائيلي لقبول هذا وتاييد
هذا الوضع ولذلك هذه التصريحات التي تاتي
من بعض الوزراء الرسميين في اسرائيل يعني
ليس من مجرد شخص في الشارع انما هذا شخص
له يعني يرفع ايده في الحكومه ويصوت وقد
يصوت على مشروع للتهجير الفلسطينيين من
قطاع غزا ولذلك هنا المسؤوليه يعني في
المحكمه الدوليه وهذه التصريحات يعني هامه
جدا وستنظر فيها المحكمه الدوليه وهيز جز
من الدعوه ضد الوزراء الاسرائيليين ويعني
ليس غريب علينا انه بالنهايه يعني مثل ما
حصل في عام 48 في نكبتنا الفلسطينيه انه
قامت الحكومات الاسرائيليه برفع يدها وكذا
هي لم يعني و كانت هناك سرديه جديده وكانه
هي ليست مسؤوله عن ذلك والخطا والخطير في
هذا الموضوع انه قد يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي
بايعاز من الحكومه الاسرائيليه من المستوى
السياسي حقيقه بطرد الفلسطينين بالقوه ط
الى خارج قطاع غز ومن ثم يرفع يده عن ذلك
يعني هذا وارد هذا الشيء هذا الخطر موجود
ويجب ان يتنبه الجميع نعم طيب لدينا الان
ايضا تصريحات في سياق اخر لنتنياهو او
نقلت على القناه الثانيه عشره بانه يدرس
اغلاق بع بعض المكاتب لتحويل المبالغ
المصروفه لها لتمويل الحرب هل نحن امام
تلمس نتنياهو لان فاتوره هذه الحرب بدات
تثقل كاهلا
اسرائيل واضح جدا انه هذه الفاتوره هي
عاليه جدا والكل يتوقع يعني كل
الاقتصاديين يتوقعوا انه ستكون هنالك
مشكله اقتصاديه كبيره جدا وهنالك بعض
المكاتب الحكوميه الوزارات بالذات ولكن
هذه الوزارات تتبع لحلفائه من اليمين
المتطرف والسؤال هو هل يستطيع حقيقه
نتنياهو هل لديه القوه ان يقنع هؤلاء
الوزراء بان يغلقوا مكاتبهم واحزاب تغلق
مكاتبهم انا اشك بذلك ولكن هنالك اصبح
مطلبا جماهيريا انه يعني يجب اغلاق هذه
الوزارات التي لا تفيد شيء انما فقط تفيد
الاحزاب اليمين المتطرف وهل لدى نتنياهو
القوه السياسيه ليفرض هذا الامر على
الاحزاب اليمنيه نحن انا يعني اشك بهذا
الشيء انه هو يصرح ولكن لا يستطيع ان يفعل
شيء وفي النهايه فاتوره الحرب الاسرائيليه
هي فاتوره عاليه جدا وحتى لو اغلق ثمن
وزارات من هذا النوع التي لا تفعل شيئا
انما لن تستطيع هذه الوزارات او اغلاقها
يعني الميزانيه التي معطاه لهذه
الوزارات لن تسد ولو
يعني زاويه صغيره في الخساره الماديه
الكبيره التي يعاني منها الان المجتمع
وسيدفع كل الاسرائيليين ثمن هذه الفاتوره
يعني في الاشهر القمه شكرا جزيلا لك من
الناصره محمود يزبك الخبير بالشون
الاسرائيليه